welcome back to drew's news and here to
spread the holiday cheer we've got the
youngest member of our drew crew it's
the shirley temple king himself leo
[Applause]
how are you kelly how are you oh great
we're so happy you're here i'm so happy
i'm here how are you i'm good honey how
are you
how was your thanks how was your guys
thanksgiving my was great and i had all
of my daughter's family um which is my
family and we just had a blast we spent
three days together cooking and shopping
and just merry meant yeah that's awesome
uh as soon as thanksgiving is over on my
family we just go straight to christmas
oh totally i think ross you like to do
your christmas tree like on thanksgiving
yeah last bite of turkey and then i'm
like let's go put up the tree i'm just
like you
yeah hi leo how was your thanksgiving
mine was good we hang out at like we
hung out at my grandmother's watch
football had turkey you know all the
thanksgiving classics all the classics
all the trimmings yep all right well
let's kick this off with a toast with
our friendly christmas cocktail leo what
have we got we have santa's hat shirley
temple now you might be thinking is this
just an ordinary temple no it's the
santa's hat shirley temple of course of
course start off with a normal temple if
you don't know what that is it it you've
been living under a rock just kidding
next together ginger ale a splash of
grenadine a bunch of ice and of course
three cherries so here's a christmas
twist all you do is you take your glass
and you dip it in some sort of like
frosting
or uh
marshmallow cream in this case we're
using marshmallow cream
let's just
get that rim all smothered in it okay
gotta get it all gooey all right
uh it's stuck
it really did get stuck yeah
but it's gonna be a good adhesive
that that that santa snow
is gonna stick right on is this is this
that is coconut uh yes coconut flakes oh
so we're gonna roll it in the coconut
and then it sticks to the rim right and
that's like the fluffy part of santa's
hat oh cute
and then we get to drink the real one
cheers you guys thank you guys and this
one is all done
i love this oh wait and then leo don't
forget that we put the candy cane in and
don't forget the maraschino cherries of
course not right here
[Applause]
i got my daily spill when i go on the
drew barrymore show but whatever
it happens it happens it happens
i'm gonna adopt that it happened yeah it
happens yep all right well when we sip
on these you want to do a little story
with us of course i love you okay great
what do you think about this do you know
who martha stewart is uh-huh yeah who is
she
she's a chef and she my favorite thing
that she cooks is cookies you know what
you're right you are so right okay well
martha stewart living reports on a new
study a new study that says if you
decorate your house for the holidays you
might seem friendlier to your neighbors
they say the lights the deer the snowmen
they all make it look like a friendly
family lives inside what do you think
about this i actually believe that
theory because
i actually believe that fury because
whenever i'm on the bus on my way to
school or back from school or
i'm in my parents car i always see them
going around like straight after
thanksgiving through november 1st i see
them popping up everywhere and our town
really goes out on christmas decorations
and when i look at them i think wow that
person really took the time
to decorate their house to make other
people happy
that's what i think and then if i'm in a
bad mood or i'm in a good mood that just
makes my day even better what do you
think
that's the whole point right
it is it's like a big welcome mat yeah
it's either saying i just want to
visually present you with joy or come on
in yeah and most of the time come on in
well we should test that theory leo
let's just go go knock on a bunch of
doors and see what happens
i'll do that okay but we'll do it
together all right listen everyone's
favorite christmas villain can we think
of it guess
yay
quench
yes
it's the grinch architectural digest
actually reports that now you can take a
vacation in the grinch's lair it's a
rental in boulder utah carefully
designed to look just like his cave and
the signs outside say leave now and get
lost kind of the opposite of the welcome
and come on in and inside you'll find
his furry green shoes and the
fantastical organ
what do you think leo would you come on
in or go away
well on one condition i'd come in and i
think you all might agree with me as
long as the grinch is somewhere else
doesn't matter if it's the north pole
or somewhere else
he just needs to be out of there
as well if he's in a grumpy spirit he
needs to be out of there because i do
not want him going around ruining my
christmas judging me
[Applause]
preach
i was um paddle boarding kayaking with
my daughter olive we went to san diego
and um the guy literally goes i was like
that's such a cool house and he goes oh
that's theodore geisel's house um i was
like dr susan he goes yeah and his wife
owned a house up on the hill
because every holiday she would get so
upset about the holidays that she would
just go to the house on the hill and
avoid everyone and that was the
inspiration for the grinch really yes
put that in your arms
i never knew that either put that in
your architectural digest article
um well leo as always we've been on this
show together since the very beginning
and as long as we are here i'd really
like to be together would that be okay
yes thank you
[Applause]
if you'd like the recipe to santa's hat
shirley temple it's on our website
[Music]